the washington post concludes that
higher numbers of black traffic deaths
are the result of
infrastructure racism before the people
act dies in ignominious death to the
whales and teeth gnashing of the media
and don lemon declares himself bias free
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have rights privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben now before we start if you love the
content you need to turn on your youtube
notifications right now ding that bell
seriously you need to do that because if
you don't you're never going to be
notified when the new videos come out so
make sure you ding that bell right now
when you get to all the news in just one
moment first
let us talk about the simple fact that
right now you are watching the
government spend more money than has yet
been created in the history of
man i mean it's really unbelievable and
this would be a great time to diversify
at least a little bit
into precious metals with my friends
over at birch gold in april alone
consumer prices increased by 4.2 percent
that's the biggest bump since 2008
higher fuel prices higher food prices
construction cost housing prices
inflation is here have you protected
your savings your investments
if you haven't yet diversified a portion
into precious metals the answer is you
have not so i'm going to tell you again
if you haven't reached out to birch gold
to diversify part of your ira or 401k
into a precious metals ira
do it today text ben to 4747.47 get a
free information kit i'm protecting your
savings with gold
i buy my gold from birch gold because
they have an a plus rating with the
better business bureau count was five
star reviews over ten thousand happy
customers
talk to them ask all your questions get
informed and then decide
if you want to put some of your money
into precious metals to work with birch
gold text ben 247 47 47.
when you make a purchase before june
30th birch gold will send you a signed
copy of my book how to destroy america
in three easy steps for free while
supplies last again text ben to 47 47
47 and protect your savings today again
text my name ben
to 47 47 47. alrighty we're going to get
to
the washington post bizarreist racial
take of the day and
there is one pretty much every day first
i got to give you the update on what
just happened in the new york city
mayoral primary so
there is a republican side of the aisle
where curtis sloa
just won the republican nomination but
let's be real about this whoever wins
the democratic nomination in the city of
new york is going to end up as mayor of
new york because new york has now
engaged in what it calls ranked choice
of voting
that means that you can win the most
votes in the first round but you may not
end up as the overall winner
because let's say that somebody who had
10 loses
and the second choice on that person's
ballot was the person who came in second
well then the vote shifts to the person
who is second now
realistically this race is pretty much
over because
the number of ranked choice voting
situations in america where somebody has
a 10-point lead
after the first round where that person
ends up losing is pretty much zero
according to harry enten
over at uh at cnn new york times
eric adams appears to be the winner at
this point eric adams who uh of course
is the former
police i believe he's a former police
officer and uh and a uh uh rather
moderate candidate at least so far as
new york city goes
he is leading right now in the clubhouse
about 30 coming in second somewhat
shockingly is maya wiley
who until recently was considered sort
of an also ranch was the only member of
de blasio's administration
to actually run she was occupying the
left lane so i guess it's not really
that big of a surprise that about 20
of voters showed up for maya wildly
since everybody else was trying to crowd
each other out of the technocratic
moderate lane so adams ended up at about
30 widely ended up at about 21 percent
catherine garcia ended up at about 20
and andrew yang ended up at about 11.
now you assume andrew yang's votes are
going to shift over
he's out and he's acknowledged she's out
you assume that andrew yang's votes are
now going to shift over
to catherine garcia which would jump her
up into the low 30s
but you would also assume that in the
second round
maya wiley's votes are probably going to
be split between the rest of the
candidates
and and what that means is that eric
adams is not going to stick around at 30
presumably many of the people who voted
for somebody else on their on
first on their ballot voted for eric
adams second on their ballot so
i think it is a fair presumption that
eric adams is likely to emerge
as the mayor of new york which once
again demonstrates the complete
rejection of the defund the police
strategy adams was very open
about wanting to refund the police uh
adams uh was
was pretty strenuous in his position
that crime had to be stopped inside
new york city it was only maya wiley who
took the far left position that the
police were really the problem
according to the new york times 82 of
the results in adams the brooklyn
borough president was the first choice
of 31.6
of those who voted in person on tuesday
or during the early voting period as new
yorkers chose a leader to steer the
city's reopening and economic
recovery maya wiley was in second with
22.3 catherine garcia was in third with
19.7
adams led in every borough except
manhattan where ms garcia held a
commanding edge because
adams seemed unlikely to earn more than
50 of the vote the contest will now be
decided
under that ranked choice voting system
and new yorkers were allowed to rank up
to five candidates in order
of preference absentee ballots also must
be counted so it could take until
mid-july
before a democratic primary victor is
actually declared and then there's the
actual general election where the
democrat
of course is favored new yorkers also
render judgment
on other vital positions in primary
races that will test the power of the
left
in the nation's largest cities the city
comptroller race manhattan district
attorney's race a slow city council
primaries among other contests
offer imperfect but important windows
into democratic attitudes and engagement
levels
but of course the mayor's race isn't
sort of the the top of the slate and the
reality is that this is a pretty ringing
rejection
of the de blasio rule in new york city
because it turns out that the sort of
radicalism that the democratic party has
fallen for
does not offer solutions it just does
not and this goes to the deeper point
and the deeper point here is that when
you attribute everything in the world
meismetic forces of racism it makes it
very very difficult to solve problems
which of course is the whole
point when you make problems difficult
to solve and then you implicate the
entire system
the notion is that you're going to have
to tear down the entire system in order
to solve the problems
everything has to be nuked you have to
just tear down everything and then
finally
once we have salted the earth and and
burn the remains of the old system
then we can build the new except that
that doesn't actually sell problems that
makes things a lot worse
in the near term so perfect example
today in the washington post
there's an article in the washington
post is at the top of their website
today titled traffic deaths increased
during the pandemic
the toll fell more heavily on black
residents report shows
a new analysis found that even before
2020's increased black people were
killed on roads
on roads at a rate almost 25 percent
higher than white people
now let's just say that you you read
that stat
right that that for a very long time
black deaths on roads have outpaced
white deaths on roads your first
thought might be who's speeding right i
mean that that might be your first
thought
that would be a natural thought in the
same way that if you read
a statistic that said that black people
are being murdered at a rate
far higher than white people and we know
that the vast majority of murder is
intra-racial it is black on black or
white on white
but black people are being murdered at a
way higher rate you might think to
yourself
well that's probably the reason is that
a lot of black people are murdering a
lot of black people
so if you see a stat in which it says
that a lot of black people are dying in
traffic accidents
you might think to yourself what is the
behavior of the drivers right because
you would think that
that's literally your first question
forget about groups with regard to
individuals
right if you hear that anybody has died
of anything your first question is what
were the circumstances
surrounding their death this is true for
anybody's death if somebody you know
dies in a car accident your first
question is how
right you don't ask questions typically
about the roads you don't ask questions
typically about the lights typically you
ask okay where are they speeding and if
somebody says oh they were speeding you
go oh okay well you know that's terrible
but you know
you're speeding right like you should
probably pay attention to the traffic
signs
this entire washington post piece is
designed specifically to ignore the
question of who is doing the speeding
right because if it turns out that black
drivers are speeding more often than
white drivers that
at least partially explains the
discrepancy between black and white
death statistics with regard to traffic
accidents instead the entire
new york times the entire washington
post article rather is dead
is dedicated to the proposition that
it's institutional racism that causes
higher levels of black deaths
so here's what the washington post and
again what this means is that solutions
become a lot more difficult
because let's say for example that the
problem really is disproportionate
speeding inside the black community and
the reason i say that is because we have
fairly good evidence from the past
that there is in fact disproportionate
speeding inside the black community so
to take an example
in the early 1990s there was a big hub
up during the clinton administration
about supposed racial
profiling on the new jersey turnpike
there's a lot of focus on this look at
these terrible cops they're pulling over
black drivers even though it was at
night it's kind of hard to see the color
of the person who's driving but they're
pulling over
black drivers at a rate higher than
white drivers that must be the latent
racism
of the new of the new jersey states and
they're just pulling black people
over then finally there was a study and
the study
was put out only about almost a decade
later
and what the study found is that a very
high percentage of the speeders
were black right it turns out that black
drivers were just
driving faster as a general rule than
white drivers were
according to this particular study right
it was it was an actual justice
department study
in conjunction with the state offices of
new jersey
and what they found was leaked to the
new york times what they found is that
while black drivers were making about 16
of the drivers on the new jersey
turnpike 25 of the speeders in the 65
mile per hour zone where
profiling complaints were the most
common were black
right black drivers sped about twice as
much as white drivers and sped at
reckless levels even more
in fact according to that particular
justice department study blacks were
actually stopped less than their
speeding behavior would predict
they're about 23 of those stopped okay
so
all of this is to not make any linkage
between genetic
skin color and how fast you drive but if
the question is
which groups of people are driving the
fastest in american life and how does
that link to traffic stops you might
think that that might be like a
consideration in the washington post
piece
no they weren't even going to consider
it in fact
and especially they weren't going to
consider it because if that were in fact
a problem if the problem were
a disproportionate number of people are
speeding in a particular area therefore
a higher number of people are dying
in that particular area more people are
driving recklessly in this particular
area therefore more people are dying the
answer to that
right the very easy policy answer to
that is okay
so you set up a speed trap right you get
a bunch of cops
you put them in the area and you have
them sign a lot of traffic tickets
because you create an incentive
structure where it makes no sense to
speed
right that is the that is the perfect
obvious policy solution
the washington post does not want that
policy solution so they go
out of their way to find alternative
explanations that are far less
less explanatory do not even posit the
possibility
that people are speeding at higher rates
on a correlative level
with regard to race even though they're
they're saying that you can measure
traffic deaths as on the basis of race
but you can't measure traffic behavior
on the basis of raise which seems like
you're ignoring kind of a rather large
factor are you not
it's sort of like the the move that that
people in the media are constantly
making where they look at big tech and
they're like well
they're just not enough engineers who
are in big tech who are black
you're like right but how many qualified
applicants are coming from the black
community
who are qualified engineers to be in big
tech and they just ignore that they
won't even put that in the story
even though that is the vast majority of
the explanation right it's not the big
tech is going around like well
i have an equally qualified black person
and white person i'm picking the white
person no one in big tech is doing that
they're doing precisely the opposite
hey so here's how the washington post
tries to explain this discrepancy
a new analysis of deaths on us roads
found that black people were killed in
traffic crashes
at a rate almost 25 than white people in
recent years a disparity that appears to
have worsened it during the coronavirus
pandemic
last year was especially grim on the
roads the number of miles driven
decreased as many people stayed home
yet traffic deaths rose seven percent
according to the national highway
traffic safety administration in large
part because of people driving faster on
empty highways
okay so right off the bat they're
acknowledging that when people drive
faster
you end up with more people dead right
so they're not this is true across the
broad population
but we cannot even measure the traffic
behavior differential between
groups when trying to explain the
traffic death differential between
groups
because to do so would imply a solution
they don't want
and we're also implied that racism isn't
the problem so you don't have to tear
down the entire system
the number of black people killed
according to the washington post climbed
the reason for the spike in black dots
is not noted in the federal report
but experts say ah the experts
experts say just as the virus itself
spread more readily through communities
of color
the increase was probably a result of
existing inequities being compounded
or possibly it was a result of
the the differential in behavior being
compounded
because if you have more people who are
speeding on the roads during this time
generally you're going
to end up with more people who speed as
a percentage of that being killed
researchers have previously concluded
that black communities tend to be
crisscrossed by more dangerous roads
during the pandemic people of color were
more likely to be employed in essential
jobs without the option to stay home
people were driving faster amid lower
traffic levels meant crashes were more
likely to be deadly
okay so the the basic premise here is
that the roads are racist right the
roads because they're in poor
communities
and because these are bigger roads with
fewer trees and people tend to speed
more on those roads
that this is the real rationale so
presumably we should have traffic
bottlenecks
in these areas which i'm not sure how to
solve many other problems having to do
with the economy having to do with
transport
if you're living in a poorer area with
fewer businesses you need to get to work
you actually don't want fewer lanes on
the roads
but put all that aside the basic notion
that this has to do with race as opposed
to with class
is another confound it turns out that
poorer areas very often are crisscrossed
with more dangerous roads i mean those
poorer areas generally exist around for
example highways
because people who are richer don't want
to live next to highways
right people who are richer don't want
to live next to big roads with lots of
traffic which is why
people who are richer tend to move out
of the suburbs for example
the nhtsa estimated that 38 680 people
were killed in crashes nationwide last
year
said 7 494 of them were black a new
study released tuesday by the governor's
highway safety association highlights
the disparities it analyzed data from
2015 to 2019 right so not including the
pandemic
okay and found that in different types
of traffic crashes black people were
killed at rates higher than white people
black pedestrians were killed at a rate
twice as high
and so who was who was driving the cars
would be the relevant
and what levels of speed were they
attaining while they were driving the
cars and by the way what was the
behavior of the pedestrians right these
are all relevant factors
to whether people are being killed in
traffic accidents or not and none of
these factors are taken into account in
the washington post
none charles brown professor at rutgers
university school of planning and public
policy
said the figures leave at transportation
officials facing a simple question quote
we've all been socialized in a way to
believe that black death is due to black
behavior
when instead we know infrastructure
influences behavior
if that is true we need investments in
quality infrastructure in black
communities
how many more black people do we have to
lose before that is the number one
priority okay so it can't be that we
focus on
lowering rates of reckless driving
lowering rates of speed
following traffic laws no we have to
restructure all the roads to what
reduce the number of lanes i mean
meanwhile to to lower the speed limit
that people are apparently ignoring the
ghsa represents state agencies that
administer federal money to tackle
problems
such as drunken and distracted driving
again we don't know the rates of that
this story does not include any of that
data how many of these accidents
included drunk driving we don't know how
many included reckless driving we don't
know how many included pedestrians
walking out into traffic
we don't know we don't know any of those
things the only thing that we know
is more black people than white people
on a percentage level are being killed
therefore racism therefore roads
okay now what's what's kind of amazing
about all of this is that then you look
at some of the statistics that are sort
of buried down in here right first you
get the
the typical equity speak from the biden
administration of pete boudej
issuing a statement that the
administration is now proposing a 20
billion dollar yeah we're going to spend
20 billion bucks on this traffic safety
proposal to reduce crashes and road
deaths as part of its infrastructure
plan buddha judge said last year's
traffic fatality rates
and the racial disparities reflected in
them are unacceptable this reflects
broader patterns of inequity in our
country et cetera et cetera et cetera
okay so then you get to the actual
differences among racial and ethnic
groups
now what's fascinating about this is who
is getting killed
in these traffic accidents because it
turns out that it is not solely income
based
right hispanics as well as native
hawaiians and pacific islanders
were killed at rates slightly lower than
whites
weird because on a household income
level hispanics do
pretty significantly worse right now
than white americans do not only that
they tend to live
in lower income areas because of that
presumably
many of the same lower income areas that
are crisscrossed with the same kind of
roads that are being blamed for higher
black fatalities
american indians and alaska natives were
killed at much higher rates
more than twice the rate of black
residents
guillermo narvaez a lecturer at the
university of minnesota who has studied
traffic safety in tribal areas said
american indian communities
are often remote and suffer from unsafe
road designs
so it must be the unsafe road designs
now nowhere in here
is is contemplated the possibility that
there are higher levels of reckless
driving
in american indian reservations for
example or higher levels of dui
example like this is not like these
possibilities are never taken into
account
human behavior is of no consequence
because equal outcome
is the supposed norm except that it's
not the supposed norm again
in any human endeavor you can take
groups of people you take this office
and the office next door and there will
be complete
disparities and differentials between
the two offices not based on race
because equal outcome among groups is
not human norm it doesn't exist anywhere
on earth
at any time in any place okay but what
does this all cover for i'll tell you
that in one second because it really is
they kind of give away the game late in
this article from the washington post
and the reason that this
is so important is because when you ex
when you
insist that equal outcome must be
the goal regardless of behavior and then
you
militantly refuse to look at individual
behavior or how behavior
agglomerates in groups you are dictating
unfairness injustice and violation of
individual rights and making life worse
for the people
who actually aren't engaging in the
behavior hey first
let's talk for a second about your
investment strategy
wall street has been telling you for
many many many years that seven percent
is a great return on your stocks well
there's some folks who say that it is
not okay trading does not have to be
particularly complex
there are people who are making 30 50
even 100 a year on their money trading
stocks even when the market is tough
carnivore trading is an anonymous team
of elite wall street strategists
they're legends among wall street heavy
hitters and now they've gone a bit rogue
because they're allowing everyday folks
like you like me to see and mirror their
amazing trades
if that sounds pretty amazing that's
because carnivore is going to let you
see the trades they are making right now
for free like full transparency
in what exactly they're doing you're not
just taking your money and giving it to
a stock broker you're actually able to
see what they are doing
on a day-to-day level go to get our
trades.com use promo code ben
and get two weeks for free if you join
carnivore guarantees you will get five
times
your subscription fee or double your
money back go to getourtrades.com
promo code ben get our trades.com promo
code ben
see website for guaranteed terms and
conditions past performance is not
a guarantee of future earnings go check
them out right now
get our trades.com promo queben and see
these expert wall street traders are
trading today so you can mirror those
trades with carnivore
c website for guarantee terms and
conditions and again past performance
not a guarantee of future earnings
alrighty so
here's where the washington post goes
with this okay so
they first try to say that it's about
the roads that because
minority communities are bisected very
often by
many lanes long distances between stop
lights few trees this signals that
drivers can go fast
it signals the drivers can go fast and
we're not going to talk about
again racial differentials and speeding
we're going to talk about what the
roads signal okay this is this is
where okay buried all the way down the
bottom the article is the actual
solution to this okay
traffic stops okay the the ghsa study
says enforcement of traffic laws is an
effective way to improve safety now
remember
very early on this article the
washington post said the ghsa
offers no opinion as to the cause
of these traffic accidents none okay but
they do offer a
possible solution enforce the traffic
laws
the ghs study says enforcement of
traffic laws is an effective way to
improve safety but acknowledges the
police stops of black people are under
renewed scrutiny
saying they should be conducted only in
a way that has the support of local
communities
traffic stops sometimes involve police
confronting black drivers to pursue
criminal investigations not related to
road safety
the ghsa analysis also found that black
people were killed in crashes involving
a police pursuit
at a rate four times higher than white
people wait um
excuse me so now the big problem is that
the police are enforcing the traffic
laws
because again no notice it's amazing
it's a consistent rule
never look at the rationale for the
disparity
only blame some sort of mesmetic
discrimination
hey again black people were killed in
crashes involving a police pursuit at a
rate four times higher than white people
do we know
who is who is running away from the
police at the highest rates of speed
have we seen each of those individual
circumstances what are the base numbers
there because
really like how many people are killed
in crashes involving a police pursuit
total you may be looking at a
differential of like eight versus two
right it's not like thousands of people
are killed every year in crashes
involving a police pursuit
again refusal to look at individual
behavior is the
is the basic media frame here
it is what they insist upon and what
does this result in
it results in more dead black people
just like with crime
okay when you don't police crime and
more dead black people you know police
traffic you end up with more dead black
people
and because if it turns out that the
underlying rationale for the disparity
is individual behavior and you won't
police the individual behavior you get
more of the individual behavior
so here's the natural outcome ap
portland oregon today police
in oregon's largest city are being
advised to no longer pursue
low-level traffic infractions including
expired plates and broken headlights
unless related to an immediate safety
threat portland mayor ted wheeler
announced tuesday
in addition if police do stop a driver
they must receive recorded consent
before searching the vehicle and clearly
informing the person they have the right
to refuse
wheeler said both changes are an attempt
to refocus on immediate threats and are
also occurring in response to data
showing a disproportionate
impact on black drivers for traffic
stops and vehicle searchers
searches while six percent of
portlanders are black he said they
account for 18
of traffic stops in the city is this
going to make the city safer
is it the answer of course is no but
when you buy into the lie that equal
outcome is the natural state of things
and that equal behavior is happening
across every group
you are going to pursue bad policy that
results in really really bad results
we'll get to more of this in just one
second first let's talk about leading
a healthier life a healthier life
doesn't mean sticking to somebody else's
strict rules
it means having more knowledge to build
smarter more sustainable habits here's
the thing about diets right you go on a
diet
then you lose some weight and then five
seconds later like this diet is terrible
and you stop dieting and then you blow
up again
like a balloon instead what you need is
a change of your
your mindset a change of lifestyle that
is sustainable
new they will help you do it noom's
cognitive behavioral approach focuses
on why instead of what it helps you
change your relationship with food
everybody's journey it looks different
noom customizes a program for you based
on your personal goals
eighty percent of new muser's finished
the program over sixty percent have
stuck with their goals for at least a
year
with noom taking care of your health is
empowering instead of stress inducing
there's no need to fear ruining the
whole program with one day off because
noom will help you get back on track
and all you need is 10 minutes a day
numa is going to fit into your life on
your terms
no grueling early mornings or huge
chunks out of your day instead you're
building
better habits with noon and my wife has
been using noob i've been using new my
parents have been using them
all of this to change your daily habits
it makes it a lot easier to think about
why you're doing what you're doing and
if you think about it for just one
moment you're likely to pursue
better individual behavior start
building better habits for healthier
long-term results
sign up for your trial at noon.com
shapiro that is
n-o-o-m-dot-com shapiro today go check
it out
right now okay so when you
when you pursue the lie that equal
outcome is the natural state of things
regardless of behavior and when you do
as ibrahim kenny says and you say
well if there is a differential in
behavior then you're
implying racial inferiority i'm not
implying anything
i'm saying that there are differences in
human behavior across a wide variety
of of human interactions and activities
that's just a fact hey forget about
rationale for a second that is a simple
fact
and refusal to acknowledge simple facts
on the ground means you're going to end
up not only in la la land but in
dangerous
la la land like for example undermining
the police and suggesting that the
police are responsible
for these disparities because if it's
not individual behavior that
agglomerates in communities at different
rates
well then it must be the police who are
really the problem
it also leads you to lie so here's mayor
lori lightfoot in chicago for example
boasting of decline in crime in her city
while the murder rate is up 30 this year
the reality is june over june so from
last year to this one
what we've seen is a downward trend in
both homicides
and shootings and if you look at where
we were in january
to where we are now we're also seeing a
downward trajectory
in both homicides and shootings were
different
than other cities across the country
every
major city in the united states last
year and this year
has seen an unprecedented rise in
violence we're down on every other major
category
but particularly in shootings um and
homicides
uh related to gun violence okay so i
mean it's amazing she's like well we're
down from last year
oh you mean when there was no cop
anywhere to be seen
so your baseline is last year
interesting
i've also noted that like dozens of
people are being shot every weekend in
chicago mayor lori lightfoot and you've
declared
racism a public health problem so murder
not a public health problem in chicago
racism a public health problem in
chicago and again you can fill in any
gap with racism
if you say okay well the murder rate is
higher in the black community in chicago
so maybe we should focus in on you know
what we can do to stop that like for
example putting more police in the
community then you'll get from lori
lightfoot that racism is responsible for
the higher murder rate in the black
community okay but
if you're using racism as an excuse not
to solve the problem
you're just making life worse for
everyone you see the same thing from the
from the biden administration all the
damn time so police
are now complaining of lagging morale
well no bleep i mean you've basically
said
across the united states the police are
the bad guys in every major metropolitan
area
and that every racial discrepancy is not
the result again of basic stats
that it's instead the result of evil
cops so there's a report
on msnbc of all places in which police
departments were talking about how they
have lagging morale which of course they
do
morale i think is at an all-time low now
we're being held responsible
for the actions of an officer that's
across the country and i don't think
that's fair we're dealing with rioting
at a level
and a sustained violence that we've
never seen before gun violence in a city
like we've never seen before
we're looking at the most catastrophic
staffing levels we've ever seen before
it all boils down to these three main
concepts of being
underfunded understaffed and
under-supported
okay and that is in portland again the
same city that just declared we're not
going to do
minor traffic stops anymore so jen saki
the white house spokesperson was asked
about this you know we've got following
police morale
of course it's peter do you see the only
reporter in the room asking him this
question
or asking her this question rather and
here is jen saki's unbelievable answer
about falling police morale remember
the white house says that it has the
capacity to control everything
in your life from toilet flow and
electricity use
all the way to whether your child should
learn
about transgenderism in third grade like
all of this should be federal policy
all of this should be controlled by the
government but they have nothing to say
about following police morale
why does the president think that
there's low morale
with police officers on the b i don't
think we're the right entity to give an
assessment of that i'd certainly look to
the police departments to give that
assessment but what i would say to you
is that the president has never
supported defunding the police
oh well they have no opinion on that
nothing none nothing to say about that
and look to the police
when that's the problem weird because
they wouldn't do this about any other
issue in american public life
if you said that there's
underperformance in black communities
with regard to high school graduation
and somebody said what does the
president say about there we totally i i
suggest you look to those communities
and ask what they think about that
he would never do that instead he would
give a high flow and answer about
systemic american racism of course we
all know this
we all know this because one of the
great avoidance strategies for members
of government is to blame big is to
blame problems bigger than themselves so
they don't actually have to take the
easy measures that are available
for them on the ground meanwhile it's
also politically palatable to say that
everything is racist because when you
call things racist it means you get to
condemn your political opponents which
brings us of course
to the death of senate bill 1 this was
the for the people act
the senate senate bill once had an
ignominious death yesterday
when republicans uh did not vote for the
advancement of the bill in a procedural
vote they didn't
kill the filibuster just to move along
with this thing there's a 50-50 split by
the way there's a 50 50 split in the
senate
um and you require 60 votes in order to
advance the bill
according to axios senate republicans
filibuster democrats signature voting
rights bill
on tuesday denying at the 60 votes
needed to advance the bill and start
debate
first of all let me just point this out
with the media the media always called
this a quote unquote voting rights bill
it is not a voting rights bill it is a
federalized
voting procedures bill they just use
propaganda terms straight from the
democratic playbook
and democrats will say well this is a
voting rights bill and immediately the
media will start parroting that this is
a voting rights bill
right if there is a if there is a bill
that suggests that
boys be allowed to compete with girls in
girl sports they will call it a
transgender rights bill
they won't call it a reclassification of
sex in sport bill which is far more
informational they always just take
whatever is the democratic euphemism for
the thing and then they just call it the
thing
so if you were just a normal reader who
doesn't follow this stuff very closely
he'd be like oh my god
the democrats were pushing a voting
rights bill and republicans oppose that
they must hate voting rights
this is this is why the media are just
garbage at their jobs
according to axios it's unexpected but
significant blow to democrats hopes of
passing a sweeping federal elections
overhaul to combat a wave of new voting
restrictions in republican-led states
again
wave of new voting restrictions includes
things like we're not going to extend
our early voting period for a month
because it's voting day not voting month
you should have voter id which is a
widely popular measure
across the united states we're not going
to allow ballot harvesting which
basically puts it in the hands of party
activists to go door to door
and pick up ballots from people which
creates not only the incentive for voter
fraud but also for packing the ballot
box
the far-reaching bill was co-sponsored
by every democratic senator except for
senator joe manchin who called it two
partisan and introduced his own
compromise bill which was promptly
rejected by republicans
manchin ultimately voted yes to move
forward and allow debate on the bill
even though he opposes the original
legislation
by the way so this was hr1
s1 is likely to go down to the same
defeat rather hr one is
far more far-reaching than s1 so s1 is
the the mansion compromise bill
this is the sort of predicate to to that
bill hr one is uh is
wild hr one federalizes ballot
harvesting it requires public funding
for a campaign so your taxpayer money
would now go to candidates that you
don't support
it's it's a crappy piece of legislation
and mitch mcconnell explained
why exactly he was opposing it
later today the senate will vote on
whether to advance
democrats transparently partisan plan to
tilt every election in america
permanently
in their favor by now the rotten
inner workings of this power grab have
been thoroughly exposed
to the light we know that it would
shatter a
old understanding that campaign finance
law should have a bipartisan referee
and turn the federal election commission
into a partisan majority cudgel for
democrats to wield
against their political opponents i mean
the number of bad provisions in this
bill
it's insane right the the what he's
talking about is the fec the fec
normally has a a three republican three
democrat
bipartisan board okay the democrats
wanted to remove one of the seats they
could have a majority on the fcc and
then presumably beat the crap out of
republicans with it it's just a bad
piece of legislation
naturally democrats are portraying the
failure to advance this bill
as some sort of defeat for democracy and
also a giant victory for you guessed it
racism we'll get some more of that in
just one second first
a lot going on this month the month of
june thankfully policy genius makes it
easy to cross life insurance off your
list so you can get back to all the
things you have to do
if you're a responsible citizen you need
to make sure that your family is insured
in case god forbid get hit by a train or
something
god forbid something should happen to
you it'll be hard enough to lose you
losing your stream of income for your
family could be absolutely devastating
get life insurance now through policy
genius why use policy genius well and
make it easy to compare quotes from over
a dozen top insurers all in one place
why compare well you can save 50 or more
on life insurance by comparing quotes
with policy genius
it could save 1300 bucks or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies the license
experts at policy unions work for you
not the insurance companies so you can
trust them to help you navigate every
step of the shopping and buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius an excellent rating on trustpilot
getting started super simple first head
on over to policygenius.com
shapiro in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
you can compare personalized quotes to
find your best price
when you're ready to apply the policy
genius team will handle the paperwork
and the scheduling
for free they're not going to sell your
information to other companies and
they're not going to add on extra fees
policy genius they are the best at what
they do
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
get started right now
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and super important
to get it right okay in just a second
we'll get to the media's overwrought
reaction to the defeat
of the for the people act first i have
some excellent news for everyone today
michael moles is new book with words
it's called speechless controlling words
controlling minds it's finally available
everywhere you buy books if you haven't
already picked it up
you should speechless masterfully covers
the topic of political correctness and
thoroughly examines it
through the lens of history it really is
a good book so if you don't understand
the dangers and relevance of pc
it's about time you do go pick up
speechless controlling words controlling
minds now available everywhere
also if you haven't been to the
bookstore lately now would be the time
because again speechless is available
everywhere now
wednesday june 23rd if you don't feel
like making a trip it's available on
amazon
in hardcover and kindle edition also
another month has passed i'm sure you
are well aware that the further left the
left goes the quicker it begins to
collapse in on itself like a dying star
but
it's not just going to do that naturally
we have to push it that is why
conservatives must get together
join together so tomorrow night join me
jeremy boring michael knowles and andrew
clavin for another
cigar pack session of backstage i'm sure
they will all be smoking cigars and i
will be suffering in their presence it
streams tomorrow
thursday june 24th at 7 00 p.m eastern 6
pm central on dailywire.com and on our
youtube channel
daily wire you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so the media response
to the defeat of the four of the people
act is of course predictably overrun
insane so joe biden put out a statement
notice he didn't actually come out and
say anything but he will
he just calls everything jim crow no
that's a lie okay just let's put it
where it belongs in the lie category
now very often people say things and
it's out of ignorance joe biden is not
ignorant
that defeating the floor of the people
act is not jim crow everyone knows it's
not jim crow because you know what jim
crow was an actual specific
regiment of law by which black people
were discriminated against
in law in the south by the state is
there anything remotely like that
in defeating the for the people act all
of that crap has been illegal
since the mid 60s it is now and i
checked my calendar today just to make
sure
2021 we are three generations removed
from a time when it was legal in the
united states to discriminate
in law okay fully 60 years
since this has happened or almost 60
years 57 years since the civil rights
act
and and the notion here is that this is
a restoration
of what was going on in 1962 in alabama
to defeat the fourth people this isn't
even we are repealing a bunch of laws
that protect black people this is
we are failing to pass a law that
completely transforms the nature of how
voting is done in the united states and
sucks it up to the federal level so joe
biden put out this statement he said
in supporting the for the people act and
defending the rights of voters democrats
stood united for democracy
they stood against the ongoing assault
of voter suppression that represents a
jim crow era in the 21st century okay
let me put it this way
for you in the media when you say that
donald trump lied when he said that the
election was stolen
fine when you say that voter suppression
is an ongoing threat in the united
states you are lying it is untrue
there is no evidence of widespread voter
suppression in the united states
period end of story you cannot
demonstrate any evidence of systematic
voter suppression in the united states
at all the notion that showing a voter
id is voter suppression
is nonsense the notion that if you get
rid of drop boxes that have never
existed in american elections before
up until an actual active pandemic and
then you get rid of those drop boxes
because you don't have a way of
supervising them properly that this
is jim crow voter suppression you're a
damned liar okay but they just keep
trotting this crap out it's not true
there is if you are the pervasive myth
that voter suppression is an ongoing
threat in the united states is
significantly more held by americans
because of the media than the notion
that donald trump legitimately won the
election but i see that you only care
about one untruth about the election the
other untruth you just keep promulgating
over and over because it pushes your
political regime
says joe biden unfortunately a
democratic stand to protect our
democracy about a solid republican wall
of opposition
senate republicans even opposed a debate
even considering legislation to protect
the right to vote
and our democracy well no they
they said that they were going to
filibuster the bill which is something
that you guys do regularly
i'm old enough to remember last year
when you filibustered tim scott's police
reform bill
it was the suppression of a bill to end
voter suppression another attack on
voting
rights that is sadly not unprecedented
the creed we shall overcome
is a long time mainstay of the civil
rights movement says joe biden
i'm sorry joe biden singing from the
hymnal of we shall overcome is like
a little nauseating and i love that
kamala harris goes right along with it
five seconds ago she was calling him a
vicious racist who was trying to
keep her out of school little girls like
her out of desegregated schools
by coming together says joe biden
democrats took the next step forward in
this continuous
struggle and a step forward to honor all
those who came before us people of all
races and ages who sacrificed and died
to protect the sacred white right okay
so just to be straight about this
no one sacrificed and died so that the
election procedures of the united states
would be federalized
ballot harvesting legalized and public
funding of elections
made law no one in america has
sacrificed and died for that particular
procedure
no one amazing how the conventional
wisdom shifted so fast
on the left from america's democracy
will survive
and thrive under barack obama too if we
don't pass this bill right now american
democracy's dead and we're finished
amazing but says joe biden the fight is
far from over nope it's over here is
vp harris declaring that the fight is
not over spoiler alert it's over
this is about the american people's
right to vote
unfettered it is about their access to
the right to vote in a meaningful way
because nobody is debating i don't
believe whether all americans have the
right to vote
the issue here is is there actual access
to the voting process or is that being
impeded
and uh the bottom line is that the
president and i are very clear
we support s1 we support the john lewis
voting rights act
and the fight is not over the fight is
over and
are you serious the ticket that she is
on
won 80 million votes in the last
election cycle
80 million votes and she's talking about
voter suppression
you want to talk about election lies
that undermine election credibility and
confidence
this would be it because guess what next
time democrats lose a presidential
election you know what they're going to
claim
voter suppression they were planning to
do it if trump had one last time
make no mistake democrats were openly
preparing the narrative that if trump
won last time it was because of voter
suppression remember the whole crap
about how
louis de joy over at the post office was
secretly removing and burning post boxes
remember this
they were pushing this crap months in
advance of the election then it turned
out as the polls shifted heavily in
biden's favor it went to
well you know probably the big threat is
that that
is that joe biden is go that donald
trump won't accept the outcome of the
this is going to be the cleanest
election ever run it's amazing how fast
they shifted from this election is
probably going to be dirty to this
election is the cleanest election ever
run
completely dependent on the polls so the
whole goal here of course
is to not push forward good legislation
the point is to polarize the american
electorate along the lines of race
and msnbc helped out here is mara gay on
msnbc she of course writes for the
washington post
and she said um this is the darkest
hours of american
history coming to life the darkest hours
of all the hours she works for the new
york times the darkest hours
now i i don't know i feel like there
have been some pretty dark hours in
american history i mean in fact
i i seem to recall that we were honoring
one a couple of weeks ago with like you
know it was juneteenth
because slavery was kind of a bad hour
in american history also there was like
the tulsa race massacre where the
president went to tulsa and talked about
it and
that was pretty dark hour in american
history seems like you know the darkest
days of world war one world war ii
pretty bad
hours seems like we just went through a
kind of rough one with the pandemic that
was pretty bad
we had the great depression we had a
vast spate of terrorist attacks
we in in the 1960s and 70s we had you
know
911 was a pretty dark like in the in the
parenting of dark hours in american
history
failure to pass a bill that usurps
voting procedure from the states does
not compute okay this is not on the list
here's mara gay again a new york times
editorial board member they just worked
for the democratic party here's marge
just being an idiot
i think this is historic for actually a
much darker reason today
and that's that we have not seen access
to the ballot
debated in this way and turned into this
partisan issue
since in fact the 1960s and 1970s
so if you're an american who grew up
with parents
who lived through jim crow as i did this
is
your history books that some of the
darkest hours of your history books
coming to life what and reminding us
that progress is not inevitable
mara gay is on the editorial board of
the new york times and she is a black
woman
speaking on msnbc about how this is a
return to the dark ages
and she's comparing the play to black
americans today to black americans in
these people are delusional they're out
of their damn minds that wasn't all on
msnbc
i i remember just sitting there nodding
as though this makes any sort of sense
i guess when your head is so far up your
ass that it's coming out your head again
it makes it very difficult to do
anything other than nod here is another
msnbc guest explaining
the same show that this is actually a
form of apartheid
this is not a democracy this is a
minority
um that is controlling this and
you know at the risk of making a
controversial
metaphor i mean we we we know what
minority rule is
and there's a term for minority rule and
that's called apartheid we fought
against that as well
the the this is history made tonight
aria on your show
a minority of americans representing a
minority of americans
uh is doing all it can to prevent
democracy
from the majority of people in this
country voting can i just point
something out real fast if we're gonna
go along pure majoritarian lines
and we're gonna break americans up by
race that is a very very dangerous thing
that is a very dangerous thing and you
know who should know that a lot of black
americans seriously because the history
of america is replete with
majoritarianism in states
directed by white people against black
people
the amazing switch in time to
majoritarianism pure majority terrorism
is a great idea
like it was never a great idea
protection of individual rights is a
good idea pure majoritarianism is a
garbage idea it has always been a
garbage
idea that is why we have checks and
balances in the constitution of the
united states it's why we're a public
not a pure democracy
just it's so frustrating but again don't
expect members of the media to know
things
that's that's silly here's pbs's yamiche
alcindor explaining
that the voting rights bill right which
is not a voting rights bill it is a
is a voting it is a voting fraud bill
effectively
the voting rights bill is about the
founders and what the founders wanted
america to be you know here's the
amazing thing
yamiche if i want to know what the
founders think about a thing
i could do this thing like i could
actually read the documents they wrote
they wrote many of them i could read
like the federalist papers i could read
the actual concept
the constitution of the united states by
the way is actually real short it's like
5 000 words
okay it would take you not even an hour
to read the constitution of the united
states and then you actually know what
the founders thought about things like
voting procedures because it's in the
constitution but here's yamiche alcindor
explaining that unless the federal
government completely takes over voting
procedure
provides public funding to candidates
taxpayer funding to candidates promotes
ballot harvesting gets rid of voter id
the founders would have been so upset
about it by the way i do love the switch
also from the left
from the founders were a bunch of rich
white slave holding racists who must be
ignored about everything too
i can't believe that they're not
upholding the legacy of the founders who
definitely wanted pure majoritarianism
what in the i'm sorry the stupidity here
and the outrageous race-baiting here on
display is truly astonishing
in talking to activists and talking to
white house officials this is going to
be a debate about
what whether or not we want america to
be the place that the founders
flawed as they may have been the
founders wanted it to be which is
a place where people could vote and
people could have access to who were the
elector
officials oh is that that's what the
founders wanted and we know that because
um
because um it's not true
[Music]
i'm sorry it's so ridiculous okay but
here's the thing you know so much of
what we've covered
in today's particular episode is about
the is about the
effect of the media on how we think
right how the washington post covers
raised how of the new york times covers
rise msnbc covers all these issues
okay and we all know what they are they
are just propagandas but here's the
thing they don't view themselves as
propagandists they don't even know their
propagandas
perhaps my favorite clip of the last 24
hours comes courtesy of
don lemon so don lemon was asked
by margaret hoover of the hoover
institute he was asked by her
about the fact that he is a biased
person right and here was his answer to
allegations of bias
when i say that the president of the
united states is a fraud and a con
that was looking at his taxes and how he
and his history of um litigation and not
paying people
these are all facts but i don't do
opinion and i know that
the difference for me is i do point of
view so i'm giving my point of view
as an american as a black man who
happens to be gay
but i'm through that lens but i'm also
i'm also i also represent cnn
and so i must tell the truth okay so
understand
this is the way leftist view the world
their view their opinion
is not opinion it's fair so they get to
shut you down
they can lie as much as they want and
call it fact because after all it's
coming from
a point of view okay that sort of bubble
mentality
leads to the spread of untruth they know
it you should know it too every time
you see what they are saying about bills
make sure you actually read the
underlying material because
at least 50 of the time they are lying
to you alrighty we'll be back here later
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime go check out the michael
knowles show today
he discusses more on the trans olympic
athlete a biological man now competing
against women by the way the oldest
athlete
in in weightlifting female weightlifting
history 43
incredible achievement for a woman who
um is a man you can hear more details
about that story over on michael's show
that is available right now
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliott feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowski
editing is by adam scievitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola cristina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
republicans shoot down the corrupt
politicians act great news
a u.s olympian fantasizes about burning
the american flag on the olympic podium
and the chief of naval operations
defends critical race theory
in the military check it out on the
michael knowles show